في جديد التطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي تشير
التقديرات الى ان تشاد جي بي تي اتابع قد
سجل 100 مليون مستخدم نشط شهريا في يناير
الماضي بعد شهرين فقط من اطلاقه الامر
الذي يجعله الموقع الاسرع نموا في التاريخ
وفقا للتقرير اجراه بانك يو بي اس وذكرت
تقرير ان 13 مليون زائر في المتوسط
استخدمت تشاد جي بي تي يوميا في يناير اي
اكثر من ضعف مستويات ديسمبر الماضي واعلنت
الشركه عن اشتراك شهري قدره 20 دولارا
مبدئيا للمستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
فقط مشيره الى انها ستوفر خدمه اكثر
استقرارا واسرع بالاضافه الى فرصه تجربه
ميزات جديده يذكر ان تشاد جي بي تي
للدردشه يجيب على اسئله وطلبات المستخدمين
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وقادر على حل
مسائل رياضيه معقده وكتابه رموز مبرمجه
ايضا
ايضا ابتكرت شركه اوبن اي صاحبه موقع تشاد
جي بي تي اداه برمجيه جديده لتحديد وكشف
النص الذي تم انشاؤه بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي وتمييزه من النصوص المكتوبه
بواسطه الانسان واشارت الى ان الاداه
الجديده تعمل على معالجه قضايا مثل
المعلومات الخاطئه والخداع الاكاديمي وسط
التزايد الانتقادات لتطبيق الشركه
بانه يساعد التلاميذ على الغش واشارت
الشركه الى ان الاداه الجديده غير موثوقه
في النصوص التي تقل عن الف حرف وفي النصوص
المكتوبه من قبل الذكاء الذكاء الاصطناعي
التي تم تحريرها لاحقا من قبل الانسان